now that we've seen how coordinates are
related between two inertial frames I
want to consider a slightly more
advanced example for a moment which is
suppose that capital V the vector
velocity of frame s prime relative to an
inertial frame s is not a constant so in
this case suppose that frame s prime has
an acceleration capital e relative to s
we now say that s prime is a non
inertial frame because it is accelerated
relative to frame s and we saw that in
inertial frames one always measures the
same acceleration for the same object
even though you'll measure different
velocities and different positions in
general that's not going to be true in a
non inertial frame in a non inertial
frame the acceleration a prime is equal
to the acceleration of frame s minus
capital a the acceleration of frame s
prime relative to s remember
capital a is 0 for s prime being an
inertial frame when capital V is a
constant but if capital V is not a
constant then capital a is not zero so
you will measure different accelerations
in these different frames now what that
tells us is that Newton's laws are going
to look a little different and let's see
how that works so now the force measured
in frame s Prime I'll call that F prime
we expect that from Newton's second law
to be the mass times the acceleration a
prime but that is the mass times the
acceleration measured in frame s minus
and capital a the acceleration of frame
s prime relative to frame s now I can
rewrite this as two terms one I'll call
F physical which represents the physical
forces acting on the object
and the second term I'm going to call F
fictitious for reasons that we'll see in
a moment so what this means is the
following
is that an observer in frame s Prime
in order to explain the motion of the
object using Newton's laws will have to
invoke not just the physical forces that
are acting on the object which might be
due to gravity or roll pulling or an
engine pushing or a hand acting on
something but will also have to invoke
an apparent force which I'll call F
fictitious that acts on everything and
in this case F fictitious is equal to
minus M capital A but that force will
not be associated will not be
identifiable with any actual real
physical interaction it's an artifact of
the choice of coordinate system it's an
artifact of the non inertial coordinate
system that frame s prime is in okay for
that reason we call it a fictitious
force and it's to be distinguished from
real physical forces of the types that
we've been talking about up until now so
you may have seen earlier that for the
motion of an object in a circle around
some some center point implies the
presence of an inward acceleration
toward the center of the circle so as a
consequence is that a rotating reference
frame for example a reference frame that
rotates with the Earth's rotation is
accelerated relative to an inertial
frame this results in a fictitious force
that has two terms a significant term
and a Coriolis term you may have come
across a Coriolis force and the
scientific force before these are
examples of fictitious forces because
they arise from the choice of coordinate
system they're an artificial force they
don't they don't correspond to actual
physical interactions but are an
artifact of the rotating non inertial
coordinate system now in this course we
will confine ourselves to inertial
reference frames and therefore will only
be considering real physical forces and
interactions
however there are advanced applications
where the use of a non inertial frame
has certain advantages and you may
encounter those as you go to more
advanced courses